many people ask me where questions and
one of them is Alexa do have bones and I
often say yes I do have holes but before
I go to work I leave them at home
this is Alexi Gila Baraka the world's
best contortionist I change 3 to 5 hours
per day to maintain my flexibility and
my other disciplines that I have in my
act
I control my body in all the shapes on
the positions and so on it is awesome
it's like feminists of development Alexi
is a contortionist for the traveling
circus company Cirque de Soleil
he's one of 45 performers from 19
different nationalities travelling with
the show Lucia Alexei grew up in Tula
Russia and has been practicing
contortionism since he was just 4 years
old when I was a kid I asked my parents
to take me to the circus show just the
watches were fun and the next day I
asked my mom to take me to the circus
studio I told her that I fell in love
with circus and since then have been
doing commotion it's almost 20 years I
started when I was 4 now I'm 24 Alexi
began performing with Cirque de Soleil
Lucia three years ago his show
celebrates the culture history and
mythology of Mexico by bringing to life
a surreal Mexican themed dream it was
the first Cirque du Soleil show to
incorporate water into the set design
and Alexi has been traveling and touring
with Lucia for hundreds of shows across
North America and he quickly gained fame
for his mind bending movements excuse
responsibility to be the best and
tortillas in the world to be the most
flexible male in the world because I
have many fans and it's responsibility
not to drop your level from here to
there because if you drop a level you
disappoint them and I feel like I don't
have rights to disappoint my problem I
don't rise to disappoint my people we
caught up with Alexi during his warm-up
before the premiere of Lucia in New York
City
my channel is called dancing contortion
it's a mix of different disciplines
the base is contortion being vendian
flexible and other disciplines such as
unbalanced elements of rhythmic
gymnastics laments of ballet dance
elements of modern dance I maintained in
my accent
Alexi warms up for about 40 to 45
minutes before each show it's one of
five stretching and cardio sessions he
has throughout the day he has to keep
his body limber and loose so he doesn't
hurt himself all practice for training
I'm very aware of each movement I do
because when I stretch I have to keep
everything under control not injure
myself but when I perform I must think
about my character in the act I think
about my presence on stage not only does
Alexi constantly have to strengthen his
body okay
Horsham ISM also demands a steady mind
it's similar to yoga and he has to learn
to control his thoughts be present with
his body through each movement the
hardest part is to maintain the balance
between flexibility and strength because
if I get too loose too flexible and I
don't care about my strength I cannot
control properly what I do on the other
hand if I get too strong
I gonna start losing flexibility it's
now about three hours before the show
and Alexi begins his makeup routine
these 45 minutes helped him get into
character Alexi portrays a mythical
creature called an elaborate it's a
Mexican creation that combines in itself
many different animals such as Swan
hunter scorpion snake and all these
animals are all in one is a lubricant
and this is me it's my interpretation of
this creature he worked with a
choreographer for six months to bring
the creature to life and as the skills
have developed through the years so has
his act once makeups done Alexi is ready
to debut his alibi his persona to New
York City but before he comes on in act
2 other master acrobats take the stage
there was hoop diving on treadmills
adagio acrobatics steer wheel and
trapeze hand balancing masts and poles
aerial straps and juggling and finally a
dark form on a platform is rolled out
onto a candle at stage the crowd goes
dead quiet
slowly Alexi unravels
and people Street
many different directions are received
sometimes they are just mesmerised I can
see complete silence in the audience I
can hear almost nothing but it performed
besides music it's very impressive
you just perform in in the silence is
amazing and Dothraki when they go crazy
and they scream and sometimes people
scream so hard that I cannot feel access
in the music I always been mesmerized
repress twists and flips and you're
unsure which body part is which he
fluidly contorts into shape after shape
[Music]
the best contortionists in the world
strikes his last pose head between his
legs chest on the floor and the audience
erupts because I realize how much I can
express myself with my body and I don't
need anything else
just money and this